If there’s anything we’ve seen so far
in this series, it’s that you need the right
materials to solve your problems.
Metals and ceramics will go a long way in
this world, but they’re not always the best choice.
Every time you bounce a ball or drive your
car on a set of tires, you’re seeing a different
kind of material in action –
one that’s able to do things metals and
ceramics just can’t.
They’re called polymers, and the world as
we know it depends on them.
[Theme Music]
Imagine there’s a 12 story building, and
up on the top floor is a fire.
Naturally, your first response would be to
call the fire department.
They’d come in their big trucks, hook up
their hoses, and put out the fire. Right?
Well, unfortunately, it’s not always that
simple.
Many fire hoses, especially older ones, only
have enough capacity and water pressure to
reach about 30 meters straight up.
And in practice, firefighters on the ground
rarely attempt to reach even half that distance
with a hose – only around the 4th floor.
Even with a ladder truck, firefighters can
only reach up to about the 10th floor until
it becomes difficult and unsafe.
But that’s still 2 stories short of where
our fire is.
If we assume that we can’t just use a different
water source or another hose, then we’re going to
need to send the water up higher than it already is.
How could we do that?
Well, one answer is by using polymers!
They’re already everywhere in this situation,
like in the trucks the firefighters drive and the
gear they wear.
And they can cause a special phenomenon that
might help with the water height problem, too.
Polymers are materials made up of long, repeating
chains of tiny molecules known as monomers
– a class of molecules that can react with
others to form much larger molecules.
In a polymer, monomers are repeated over and
over again until there are hundreds, thousands,
or even millions of them in a long line.
Typically, polymers have lower densities
compared to metals and ceramics, and they
aren’t usually as stiff or strong.
So you probably shouldn’t try to build a
house out of them.
Many polymers are also extremely ductile
and pliable, so they’re easily formed into more
complex shapes.
They also don’t generally react easily with other
chemicals, making them a good material for volatile
environments like a chemistry lab.
But since polymers depend on the monomers that
they’re made from, you can get a better sense of a
polymer’s characteristics by looking at its composition.
Ones that have longer chains tend to show
more elastic properties.
These are often called elastomers, and are
mainly found in rubber materials.
Take a rubber band, for example.
The molecules in the polymer can be all
clumped together, or stretched out, like when
you pull on the rubber band.
On the other hand, polymers with larger and
more complex monomers tend to be stiffer.
You can also stiffen polymers through a process
called cross-linking.
That’s when polymers are bonded with
each other to form a 3D, net-like shape
called a polymer network.
Have you ever heard of vulcanized rubber?
It’s the stuff used to make things like tires,
like the ones you might find on a fire truck.
Well, vulcanization is the process of using
sulfur to cross-link and strengthen rubber polymers!
Tires probably aren’t the only polymers
that you’re familiar with.
Chances are good that you use plenty of
them every day, like the ones you’ll find in
plastic bags and seat covers.
And while it’s easy to take polymers for
granted, they’ve only been widely used since
about the 1940s.
But that doesn’t mean they don’t have
a special place in history.
Research suggests that the first time people really
used polymers was back in pre-Columbian Mexico and
Central America, around 3,000 years ago.
Back then, they took latex, a milky, sap-like
fluid found in some plants, and mixed it with
juice from the morning glory plant.
This juice had sulfur in it, which effectively
vulcanized the latex and made it less brittle.
And from there, they were able to make
rubber goods like sandals, rubber bands,
and even bouncing balls.
You can actually do a pretty similar and simple
experiment if you want.
All you have to do is mix some common glue
you’d find at a school supply store, which contains
a polymer chain known as polyvinyl acetate,
with a borax solution, which will act as the
cross-linker for our mixture.
And then you just combine that with some cornstarch.
Stir them together, roll it around in your
hand, and poof!
You got yourself a rubber ball!
You can also do similar experiments to make
a cool slime if you change up the ingredients
and measurements a bit.
Now, even though we have evidence that polymers
were used thousands of years ago, it still took a while
for the modern world to find the right applications.
That’s because we don’t always get things
right the first time.
For example, if you’ve ever played a game
of pool or billiards, you know that the balls
don’t usually explode.
But that wasn’t always the case.
Go back to the 1870s and celluloid, a hardened
material made from the natural polymer cellulose,
was used to make billiard balls instead of
ivory, which was what they were made from
before that.
Problem was, celluloid was highly flammable, and when
the billiard balls hit each other just right, they would
explode on the pool table, which happened quite often.
Today billiard balls are still made of polymers,
just ones that are far less explosive!
We also tried using cheaper, more flammable,
substitutes for silk back in the day.
Of course, having more flammable fabrics,
especially for clothing, is obviously a bad thing.
This all happened because it wasn’t until
about the early 20th century that we had a decent
understanding of what a polymer was.
That’s when Hermann Staudinger, a German
chemist, entered the picture.
At the time, most chemists thought polymers
were made up of small molecules bundled together
by unknown forces.
But in 1922, Staudinger suggested that these materials were made up of larger molecules arranged in the long molecular chains that we know them to be, all bonded in a line.
His work earned him the Nobel Prize for
Chemistry and laid the foundation for the explosion
of the plastics industry in the 20th century.
Scientists then began using polymers as synthetic
substitutes, like synthetic rubber and nylon.
World War II also had a big impact on the
polymer world.
Wartime restrictions on natural materials
helped drive the polymer industry into existence,
especially the creation of synthetic polymers.
During the war, the Allies used polymer to create large
inflatable tanks that served as decoys on the battlefield,
part of what was known as the “Ghost Army.”
These fake tanks tricked enemies into
thinking Allied forces had far more strength
than they actually did,
or that there was a giant army in an area
where there weren’t really any soldiers at all.
The Ghost Army reportedly saved thousands
of lives – I’d call that a win for polymers!
And a win for us engineers, because they set
us up for the world of polymers that we have today.
It’s this world that’s helped us keep
firefighters safe, using polymers to design better
gas masks and other parts of their gear.
Just like with other materials, some kinds
of polymers get used more than others.
The ones that you’ll most likely come across
are polyethylene, or PE, polyvinyl chloride, or
PVC, and polyethylene terephthalate, or PET.
Polyethylene is the most common plastic in
use today.
It’s primarily found in packaging materials,
like plastic bags and bottles.
Polyvinyl chloride comes in two main forms:
rigid and flexible.
Rigid forms of PVC are often used in buildings
and construction for things like plastic pipes
and the frames for windows and doors.
They need to be strong, not just for daily
use, but to hold up for as long as possible
in a disastrous event like a fire.
PVC can also be made softer and more bendable
by adding in a plasticizer, which can help it be more
flexible or make it less thick and viscous.
You’ll find flexible PVC in imitation leather,
flooring, and inflatable products.
Polyethylene terephthalate is a bit different.
It’s spun into fibers and used for clothing,
as well as other things like photographic
film and magnetic recording tape.
These are some of the more common ones, but
there are a bunch of other unique polymers too!
There’s nylon, which is a tough, lightweight,
and elastic polymer, and kevlar, a strong
fiber with bullet-stopping power.
We also have teflon, which is highly water
resistant and one of the slipperiest solids.
And interestingly enough, if you add a very small
concentration of a polymer to a moving fluid, the
friction within the fluid can decrease by up to 80%.
That’s called polymeric drag reduction.
The end result is a fluid that can flow even
faster with the same pressure behind it.
Which is really important if your fire hose
can only safely reach the 10th floor and you
have a fire on the 12th.
So now we have a way to solve our problem!
Add in a small concentration of polymeric
material and voila, the water can now reach
the 12th floor and put out the fire!
Now, in reality, this probably wouldn’t
be the way to go.
It can be dangerous for firefighters to try
and reach tall fires from the outside.
And with one as high up as this, they’d likely
try to find a different solution, like trying to
attach a hose to an adjacent building.
But as a thought exercise, it’s a great
way to see some of the more innovative uses
of polymers and what they can do.
Today we learned all about the third main
type of material that you’ll encounter as an
engineer: polymers.
We found out that they’re made of long,
repeating chains of smaller molecules known
as monomers.
Then we saw the strange history of polymers
and what led to how we use them today.
Finally, we went over some of the more common
polymers and how the special properties of
polymers could help us in a dangerous situation.
I’ll see you next time, when we’ll talk
about electrical engineering materials.
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
And, if you’re interested what's going on
with our climate, check out Hot Mess,
which explores climate science, the effects of
climate change, and how we can create a better
future for our planet and ourselves.
Crash Course is a Complexly production and this
episode was filmed in the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney
Studio with the help of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.